hello everyone and welcome back to
versus that most beloved of competition
shows where no one not any one of the
combatants has ever actually showed up
to defend themselves in studio thus i
your intrepid host mark ellis get to be
judge jury and doc ock for all the world
to see and today on the show it's
heartthrob city oh thanks i mean you
already got me and adding to this will
be two tinseltown teen titans
ouch they're not teenagers really well
you could have fooled me they play young
and they began their fresh-faced acting
careers at precocious young ages so help
me welcome timothy chalamet and tom
holland to the show
again not literally they will not show
up even if i invited them let's not get
our hopes up i would rather be dead in
one corner we have tom holland he of the
itsy bitsy franchise spider-man i'm not
spider-man i mean what would make you
think that i was sweating man teensy
weensy video game flicks like uncharted
and he even does big time animated
movies such as onward in the other
corner it's timothy chalamet who sanded
a formidable career in blockbusters like
dune critically acclaimed coming-of-age
tales like call me by your name and he's
such a talented guy he was invited to a
film called little women they're both
the next generation of uber talented
a-list movie stars capable of generating
hundreds of millions of dollars in one
movie and getting nominated for tiny
gold prizes in the next but today there
can be only one which speaking of
highlander if they ever reboot that
franchise i know two fellows who you
might want to call in the meantime
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
season of giving round four s'mores and
then we'll do a wild card round that i
really hope also involves food somehow
and if you thought timothy chalamet and
tom holland were just lucky struggling
actors who booked big parts because
they're incredibly dashing then i want
you to take one last look at your bubble
because it's gonna burst they showed
preternatural performing abilities at
absurdly young ages so their experience
belies that youthful exterior please
turn away i feel shy about my new
muscles tom holland originally thought
he'd be a dancer and he's got years of
onstage chops as billy elliott to prove
it meanwhile charlemage attended a new
york high school centered around music
and the arts and he's become something
of a fashion icon these days it's all
part of a plan
so maybe this whole movie star thing is
a side gig to these folks but for us
here on verses it is those film careers
that are going to take center stage i'll
save room for a holland lip sync battle
or a timothy rap bar's escapade to be
the tiebreaker all right studio audience
what do we say around here
life seems super sad all right we don't
uh we don't have a crowd let's get it on
round one box office
yeah all that talent comes in handy i'm
sure but will the hard-working folks of
earth fork over their cash to see you on
the big screen
um you do know one of these fellows
plays spider-man right before we get to
that lad who booked the role of peter
parker let's first take a look at
timothy chalamet who auditioned for the
role of budding photographer pete to see
if he'll be any competition to the web
slinger
physically or metaphorically if we're
counting outer space spice movies then
yes you know sometimes i amaze even
myself relax han solo i'm talking about
dune the denny villeneux hit that
stirred up just shy of 400 million
dollars worldwide and that's not even
timothy's biggest hit that takes
primarily in space i think you just
can't bear to let a gorgeous guy like me
out of your sight who what the star wars
people in this i'm giving tim some
credit for his role as young tom in the
christopher nolan smash hit interstellar
nolan loves nothing more than when you
see his movies on the biggest canvas in
town and that film rocketed off with 651
million dollars in the bank and when
xiaomi has prominent roles on earth he
does okay too little women hauled in 218
million dollars and the critically
adored 2017 double bill of lady bird and
call me by your name teamed up for over
120 million that's certainly good enough
numbers to make most any competitor
perspire but how about spider-man well
he might not even need that alter ego to
make a statement here in round one
here's some non-mcu hits that tom
holland has been involved in like
timothy chalamet he was once upon a time
young and is one of the sons in the
impossible he helped that film earn 169
million dollars worldwide then he lent
his voice to animated features like
spies in disguise which would gross 165
million bucks and he also does
live-action ish voice-over work for
projects like doolittle which somehow
made
251 million dollars worldwide really
that's what it said on the news
and the news never lies there's no
judgment here i'm just um wow
i didn't have any better ideas holland
also starred in uncharted based on the
huge video game franchise and that film
pretty much ties dune at just a few sand
granules short of 400 million dollars
all right so we got us a ball game well
we had us a ball game allow me to put
this into perspective timothy chalamet
legend to me has averaged 170 million
dollars per film thus far in his
splendid ever expanding filmography his
total box office receipts thus far
equals 1.5 billion dollars which is a
lot of money however spider-man no way
home took in 1.8 billion dollars by
itself far from home added in another
1.1 billion to the fun and spidey
homecoming kicked things off with 878
million dollars across the globe that
ain't even a half of it we first met
pete and spider boy in captain america
civil war which brought in over 1.1
billion dollars and since we all liked
that movie so much why not include
spider-man in those little adventure
movies infinity war crossed that two
billion dollar line and end game almost
made it to three bills settling in at
almost 2.8 billion dollars before
selling what i imagine is a lot of
blu-rays all right now it's all over but
the shouting so allow me to yell this
tom holland is
26 27 it's gross thank you his films
have already amassed over 11 billion
dollars total making for a perfect
average of
796 million
now we should point out he doesn't get
to keep all that money i assume we're 50
50 right but it's still a solid opening
line when you're meeting new people i am
the most famous person in the entire
world
man i'm still broke timothy chalamet may
have found a franchise of his own in
dune but for now it's the current film
property champ the mcu and it's golden
spider goose man that's not right who's
top dog it's a lot of animals kind of
like that doolittle movie 251 million
dollars huh what's that man tom holland
wins round one going away and is now up
one to nothing i'm trying to as much as
possible not
participate in our economy i don't like
money
round two tomato meter slash audience
score there's no way to sugarcoat it
chalmette played well in round one and
still took it on the chin mainly because
beneath tom holland's boyish exterior
lies a box office mad titan that would
make thanos cringe in fear yeah
definitely
maybe
maybe
but now we've arrived at the round that
isn't about how rich you are it's if
those buck churning talking pictures are
actually any good and yeah then mcu
flicks are pretty well received but
don't forget do it also counts we're
finished and for the record i might lean
just as heavily into young willy wonka
jokes if that movie had already come out
at the time of this battle doolittle is
at 15 on the tomato meter so the critics
were not having it i mean when you put
it like that but chalamet's low point
isn't much higher love the coopers from
2015 is it 18
what have you done lately
oh great artiste
and with that we've gotten the worst out
of the way onward and upward too well
onward that movie onward tom holland and
chris pratt are brothers in this
animated adventure and it's a fresh 88
percent on the tm that's good but only
if you wanted the seventh highest rated
tom holland flick on this metric he's
got six films in the 90s endgame snaps
its way to the lead dog at 94
followed by no way home at 93 percent
homecoming at 92 percent and both far
from home and civil war at 90 percent
the other film at 91 percent is lock
which i mean come on that's the movie
with tom hardy driving a car for 90
minutes that's the whole movie it's a
riveting acting piece but i guess tommy
is a voice on the phone at one point so
sure have at it kid cool
timothy chalamet has four films at 90 or
better making the overall high mark for
either competitor with lady bird at 99
percent little women's at 95 percent
call me by your name as at 94 percent
and miss stevens is at 91 percent so
we're getting competitive here dunes at
83 percent for timothy holland has the
impossible at 81
so overall it's a tight ball game as tom
has a 68 tomato meter film average to
chalamet 66 percent average which means
we head over to the audience score side
of the veggie patch and it appears my
jokes thus far have made quite a few of
you angry someone's been a bad boy
doodle is fresh at 76
point taken i stand down though i still
prefer rex harrison or eddie murphy
sounds thoughtful of somebody really
people are often nice tom holland's
all-time high with the audience is an
mcu film and a spider-man flick no way
home with all of its many arachnid men
is it 98
onward and far from home are tied at 95
percent and even as mark wahlberg says
unchatted climbed to 90 percent here
finding the high ground against its
tomato meter score which is anakin
skywalker at 40 percent
audiences weren't quite as high on lady
bird as the critics were although the
film is still safely fresh here at 79
percent however dune did climb up to
meet the audience score at 90 percent
and little women held strong with a 92
percent on this measurement beautiful
boy also rose from a tomato meter of 67
percent to reach the audience with 77
percent but remember that precipitous
increase that tom holland had with
onward timothy shallow may also pulls
that magic trick here but with the best
picture nominee don't look up is rotten
on the tomato meter with 55
but the folks at home dug it to the tune
of 78
fresh all told timothy chalamet is fresh
with audiences as he can brag about a 71
average per movie can tom holland beat
that
yes yes he can his average is 76 and
that's more thanks to his own spider-man
adventures than those big avenger
team-ups that's more than enough to
press me and no i'm not just siding with
the guy who's made 11 billion dollars
with movies because maybe he can help me
out with a car payment or two tom
holland has now earned his second point
fair and square by winning round two and
he's suddenly up on fellow celebrated
thespian timothy chalamet two to nothing
how dare you define me
round three season of giving and here's
where timothy chalamet has his best
opportunity yet to notch that elusive
first point remedy this failure in fact
winning a round on the hit show versus
might be the only thing he hasn't yet
done and lucky for him the season of
giving round refers to all those award
show voting bodies whose job it is to
dole out prizes for playing pretend this
round will be taken by who has the more
decorated mantel although i'm sure these
two have more than one mantle on which
to adorn statues ribbons slime because
the nickelodeon awards are prestigious
mtv awards can count as well and i'm
even going to toss in some magazines tom
holland won the gq superhero of the year
title in 2021 and let's be honest both
of these fellas at some point will be
people magazine's sexiest blake shelton
of the year before it's all said and
done
hey you put on some muscle
i did
no
but enough preamble let's get to that
most celebrated event of the season the
super bowl of movies the academy awards
let's get weird boom tom holland has yet
to be nominated for an oscar but he's
won three academy of science fiction
fantasy and horror film awards and
anytime an academy recognizes you for
doing anything other than serving
detention it's a good day the only way
to really be cool
is to follow the rules but timothy
chalamet has been to the dance as a
contender when he was nominated for best
actor for his turn and call me by your
name he would also go on to earn a
nomination from the golden globes for
that portrayal and then the next year
for his role in beautiful boy gotta see
someone through this is kind of working
out for me right now but where chalamet
really has the edge is the sheer amount
of tuxedos he's had to rent not to
accept awards himself but just to enjoy
the films he start and receive a claim
from the front row he's been in five
best picture nominees already in his
young career can you name them all while
i buy you some time it's interesting to
note that tom holland has already
started five films that have grossed
over one billion dollars would that
factoid have been better served in the
box office round
probably don't ever apologize for being
the smartest one in the room but then
you wouldn't have had time to come up
with the following five timothy chalamet
flicks that had been nominated for
oscar's top honor are you ready dune
don't look up little women call me by
your name and ladybird you want to know
how many won
spider egg
i like how ruthless you are
none yet but the bottom line is if
timothy chalamet is in your picture you
got a fighting chance supposed to be a
surprise that's not to shortchange tom
holland and his ability though he's
chosen a different route thus far in his
career and it served him okay plus he's
won a bafta award and an mtv movie award
for his performance in no way home sadly
he didn't win mtv's most coveted award
the best kiss with zendaya that year
those two lost out too of course poopies
and the snake from jackass forever have
we done a versus on jackass that's gotta
happen sooner rather than later right
wow
he's talking smack the same could be
said for either holland or chalamet
taking home some gold for now it's
chalamet whose 40 award wins total ranks
higher than holland's 24 victories and
thus timothy wins his first round of the
day now we got us a ball game it's 2-1
spider-man over paul this
is special the tradies from the kid from
dune sitting right here come on
round four s'mores that lovely food
where you take the graham and the mallow
and the chocolate was a sugary coated
disguise for this round that will be won
not by who makes the most delicious
confection on the range but by who has
shown the most range in their ever
growing acting career luckily for tom
holland this round will not be won by
who makes the best s'mores because
xiaomi is going to turn into freaking
willy wonka at some point in the near
future playing that role will require a
ton of range but before we prognosticate
which roles these folks could knock out
of the park on some distant day let's
look back on what they've already
accomplished in their young careers
treating me like a kid all the time
warning to everyone over the age of
eight watching this vid it's gonna hurt
you know i want to root for actors of
all ages but not when they're 10 right
but that was pretty much the case for
tom holland when he was cast in the
heart-wrenching the impossible alongside
adult acting heavyweights that came out
wrong actors who would reach full
maturity will say you and mcgregor and
naomi watts it's not a role you ease
into because it involves saving santa
claus that's some real emotion that
every performer on screen has to convey
and tom holland was a legitimate
discovery
timothy chalamet also showed talent and
wisdom beyond his years in interstellar
albeit in a role that saw him on screen
for let me check my notes here
four seconds he also provides a deft
audio touch with voiceover while matthew
mcconaughey is thinking back on his life
and you can hear the emotional bandwidth
emerging from chalamet then we saw him
in miss stevens in a role where he'd
expertly maneuver those wanton emotions
that all teenagers have rebellion and
angst countered by laughter and longing
all tossed into one giant vitamix it's
pretty cool that's cool
a part that required a similar summoning
of every experience leading up to that
point for holland was cherry tom would
later say that he had to go to some of
the darkest places he'd ever been
emotionally physically and he has no
desire to go back ever so don't hold
your breath for a sequel on that one as
far as spider-man goes yeah remember
that week where we might not get a deal
done between two giant studios to keep
tom holland in the mcu as spider-man it
was a weird time scary for a lot of fans
but at least the stuff got worked out
and we've been rewarded with more
adventures as peter and spidey grow up
before our very eyes
since civil war we've seen the dual role
progress from a kid happy to just be
there to someone who finally found their
father figure in iron man
that's not a hug i'm just grabbing the
door for you we're not we're not there
yet
to having to say goodbye to that daddy i
just really miss him only to think he'd
found another one in mysterio it's
really nice
to have somebody to talk to about
superhero stuff you know but at the end
of the day we now know that the only
people you can truly trust are those who
dress identical to you from a different
universe peter yeah
oh and he might be single again because
of the wizard guy with the spells i'm
struggling to keep up with all the
multiverse stuff but i'm enjoying the
ride it's not every day you get to watch
a superhero worry about the last stages
of puberty college entrance exams i am
so far beyond high school right now
death bullies all of it this is not what
it looks like and speaking of longing
for someone to look up to what i
appreciated about uncharted is that it
could have just been tom holland playing
a version of peter parker but he's got a
different charisma about him here his
new york city bartender may look like he
needs to card himself on a nightly basis
but when he matches wits with mark
wahlberg sully he's not looking for a
mentor so much as an ally it's not the
toughest part holland will ever play
except for that whole maintaining a rock
hard six-pack thing but we do see shades
of a different type of hero that he's
been playing but there's a reason why so
many films featuring timothy shallow may
have been nominated for oscars that kid
has chops for days and call me by your
name he pulls off one of the toughest
things a person can do or an actor can
convey coming to grips with one's own
sexuality and being able to take
ownership despite the fear and anxiety
that can come from it juxtapose that
with his turn as the bro e boyfriend and
lady bird where he could have just been
a one-note bad influence instead xiaomi
lends a real humanity to a 2d character
and that third dimension shows us that
he's the embodiment of the freedom that
lady bird craves beyond her small town
limits in beautiful boy he
heartbreakingly grapples with addiction
little women sees him handle rejection
like that hillside scene where he can
barely hide his pain why are you saying
this and in dune he um well you know
he's got the fate of the universe in his
hands that's true so paula tradies might
actually be able to match wits with
peter parker just in terms of handling
that chosen one pressure uneasy lies the
head that wears the crown
stark said you wouldn't get that because
it's not a star wars reference it might
be more of a career path win than
anything else and stan lee knows that
tom holland enjoyed the spoils of his
imdb with that box office round but
while he was racking up the bucks
timothy chalamet took advantage of
hitting plum rolls out of the park and
turning easily throwaway characters into
real people that we can't take our eyes
away from both gentlemen are going to
have a whole lot more to say as these
s'mores get toastier with each passing
award season but for right now the range
round goes to wonka which again i don't
think i need that movie but like a
delicious chocolate bar i may not be
able to resist timothy now has tied the
match it's two to two that's hella tight
and now it's time for the wild card
round iconic moments
yep it's the moments that made these two
actors superstars that will determine
the winner of this stage and thus the
match and it's more of a fair fight than
at first it may appear for every
high-flying daredevil tactic pulled off
by spider-man there's that other guy
who's making us cry feel emote it is the
space between you fight not for
yourselves fight for that space fill
that space make it kiss you
make it mass make it impenetrable make
it yours make your day glenn
but i've also gotten misty-eyed at comic
book movies as well including a couple
of moments that involved a snap
uh-oh i'm not feeling so good
i'm kidding you can't get rid of your
host that easily i'm like a taller
sexier cockroach with less legs and a
bigger thorax do i have a thorax that's
that's wrong
that's wrong we'll research it well
before i regale you with spider-man's
greatest hits may i remind you how paul
with tradies is able to kick some
serious ass in dune i know he's barely
fitting into his adult britches when we
meet him that's rude but when push comes
to shove he punches back as does nathan
draken uncharted i don't care who you
are you're going to pay attention to a
sweet plain free fall battle point break
a few of them fast and mad car movies
but uncharted really threw us right into
the free fall from the word go and i
know from experience i wasn't aware i
was sitting in a 4dx theater until that
opening sequence it's better than a cup
of joe in the morning i think the poets
might disagree speaking of planes and
airports it's memory lane o'clock
captain america civil war wow it's so
weird how you run into people at the
airport anything that's weird definitely
weird sure we were pumped to see cap and
tony gomano a mono and for black panther
to make a sterling debut but why did
spider-man showing up elevate that
tarmac scrimmage to another level the
kid from brooklyn met the arachnid from
queens and peter proved that he wasn't
just about boyish enthusiasm he could
hang literally with the best heroes in
the world and he also taught us that it
pays off to study really old movies you
ever seen that really old movie
and prize strikes back did you have to
say really old movie jesus tony how old
is this guy i don't know i didn't
carbonate him he's on the young side
couldn't he just have said hey remember
an empire strikes back we all would have
gotten it just the same and felt better
about our own ages moving on spider-man
homecoming reinforced the fact that tom
holland can play on the same court with
superheroes but can you handle the
pressure of a school dance it's always a
nerve-wracking experience beating your
crush's rents try having her daddy also
be your new arch-nemesis for all the
reasons i didn't want my daughter to
date
what a game of mental chess that car
ride to the fish under the sea event was
and i love how we can vastly between the
innocence of a kid trying to do too much
like the boat sequence versus a man
stepping up when he has to such as when
he cranks up ac dc to save the day in
far from home oh i love led zeppelin the
heartbreaking part of the father-son
relationship for timothy chalamet and
beautiful boy is that he has a loving
dad played by steve carell but too often
the lure of the dark side of human
nature supersedes that bond and a great
or awful display of tug-of-war is the
diner scene if you just want to cry for
both of these folks for different
reasons have at it i did the same thing
i wanted to go like this
and with characters like elio from call
me by your name or even laurie from
little women chalamet can show off his
dance moves in a variety of ways and the
fireplace sequence near the end of call
me proves the next level chops of
timothy chalamet good actress can
convince us that their feeling emotions
great ones make us feel them too but
sometimes we'll get a moment that
captures all the emotion we want and
acts as a pivotal moment in the world's
biggest blockbuster as when peter has to
say goodbye to mr stark it was so
heartbreaking when parker wasn't feeling
well at the end of infinity war but now
the roles are reversed tony did what he
had to do and peter must now accept that
he's on his own albeit with a suit that
will definitely conjure some of the
fresh memories that that cocky genius
built into it
if we're tied as of the moment it's hard
to not lean towards no way home not
because it was fun seeing toby mcguire
and andrew garfield join the reigning
spider-man but because tom holland was
able to hold his own against two fellow
actors who know a thing or two about
delivering a line in the clutch you know
it's what we do we'll have many more
memorable moments from both timothy
chalamet and tom holland hopefully for
decades to come but as of now it's
holland who wins out he gets the wild
card round point and thus wins the match
and my co-host of the rotten tomatoes is
wrong podcast jacqueline coley may never
forgive me for giving tom the win over
her beloved timothy so maybe we can have
her two bows timothy and bill hader duke
it out into future verses
time will tell but in the meantime
thanks to both these guys not just for
being good sports but for all the great
performances they've blessed us with
over the years and again they're still
both in their 20s right they're born in
the mid 90s
you two may be on the top of the world
but you'll never know the joy of chewing
cinnaburst while chugging a crystal
pepsi i'll tell you about it someday
and of course this is all just my
opinion now it's your turn dear viewer
hit me up on social media at mark ellis
live and give me your thoughts on this
epic match up featuring stars of the
next generation and keep it right here
at rotten tomatoes for all the latest in
the world of movies tv and everything in
between thanks for watching versus i'm
mark ellis
it's not uh oh yeah you need the thing
all right see you later